white knight but now the threat is  white's rook coming up to the top of the  board  check and the white queen is protecting  it so black's rooks have to just huddle  together  can can liam just continue uh on the  attack  maybe step forward with his queen i know  he can't do that maybe just retreat the  queen i thought you're about to say step  forward with the king again  no he steps forward with the rook okay  so now the big threat is rick takes rook  and uh actually there's lots of threats  in the uh  uh go forward with your king ah he  doesn't go forward with his king  but he blocks him with the knight and  that's uh okay  okay so everything holding together um  glued well together by  white now everything's protected whoa  unless we've missed this last this is  gonna be amazing oh it's checkmate liam  sacrifices his queen  and wins in style rook takes queen is  met by rook recaptures  and that's checkmate levon resigns  wow what a game what a day for  liam he is the winner